Film Courage: Let’s say I finish my first
draft…what am I doing?
Who am I showing it to?
What am I thinking?
Vicki Peterson, co-author: Well the very first
thing you should do when you finish a first
draft is go out and celebrate, truly.
There are so many people who start a draft
and never finish.
And by just finishing a draft you’ve probably
put yourself in the top ten percent of all
screenwriters just by doing that one thing.
And seeing something to completion, seeing
a first draft come to life that’s a really
huge accomplishment, especially for a first-time
writer.
So we really encourage people to take note
of that, to celebrate.
And then I would say after that take a little
break from writing so that you can be fresh
so that you can come back to it with new eyes.
Now the first draft is just the very, very,
very beginning of a very long journey towards
being produced or being a professional screenwriter.
And so after you’ve had a chance to take
a break it’s really important to go back
to that draft and look at it through the eyes
of an editor to really look at it objectively
so that you can rewrite it.
And in our book [Notes to Screenwriters: Advancing
Your Story, Screenplay, and Career With Whatever
Hollywood Throws at You] we have a whole chapter
on rewriting and things that you can do to
get your script ready.
When it’s ready to be seen by eyes other
than your own we generally recommend that
this is where you would send it to your writer’s
group, this is where you would get professional
feedback where you really need mentorship,
where you really need somebody who can guide
you through the rewrite process.
And once that happens, once you have a working
draft that you can send out, that’s when
you start contacting producers, that’s when
you can start sending it out to festivals
and contests and things like that.
Generally speaking we find that people have
more success working with producers (independent
producers) and teaming up with people in that
way as opposed to trying to get an agent or
a manager right out of the gate.
It’s pretty rare that that scenario happens
with a first-time writer.
So work with the connections that you have,
make sure that you’re networking, make sure
that you’re sending it to people that you
know.
And of it really is truly ready to send out
to the world, you should be getting back some
pretty positive responses at that time.
Barbara Nicolosi, co-author: I would say also
that the thing about a first project is you’re
not writing it to be made.
You’re writing it to be your calling card.
So every writer needs to have a couple of
scripts that they can show as this is an example
of what I can do.
I know my craft, I know the business of this
art form, I can martial people’s emotions,
I can take a character on a journey because
nobody is going to buy your first script or
your first two scripts.
You’re looking to get work.
You’re looking for people to say “Wow.
You know what you’re doing.
I have this little project and we need a writer
for it.”
So that’s why you don’t want your first
project to be your kind of weird, highly-stylized
passion project because nobody wants to make
that.
They’re looking to see can you do a good
basic job at your craft.
We need a writer to deliver.
Vicki Peterson: That’s strong in tone and
genre and can really deliver strong characters
and a plot that moves.
Barbara Nicolosi: So a lot people have the
wrong sample script, they have the wrong idea
of it and then they are just constantly holding
out hope that somebody is going to buy this
script and they miss the fact that no, that’s
not what it’s for.
For somebody starting out, you’re trying
to get work and you’re trying to show you
know your business, you know your field.
We stress that with writers all the time.
The truth is the first script probably nobody
should ever see, your second script very rarely
should anybody see.
But okay now you’re in your third project,
your fourth project and now you’re getting
stuff that should be seen.
But again, know what you’re doing with it.
This is a sample of your best work, it’s
a sample of what you can do.
So again, two different projects, one is more
your particular voice the other one really
shows us as Vicki says you understand genre,
you understand the basic structure of storytelling
because that’s this mysterious thing to
producers, directors and actors and they don’t
know where that comes from and they need writers
who can do that.
And so you’ve got to be able to show I’m
one of those people who can do that.
The main point of creating this is to be your
sample.
Vicki Peterson: And what’s also extremely
important is that this is your first script
and you’ve gotten it to a place where it
is ready to show people.
Typically the best thing you can do at that
point is to set it aside and write something
else.
And write your second script and get that
to a place where you can show people because
then you have two things that you can show
because this business is funny that way.
They see something that they like that is
maybe not for them, they’re going to say
“Wow, I like this writer.
What else do they have?”
And if you don’t have anything else then
that says that you’re not ready yet to be
a professional.
So you really need to have some things under
your belt.
Barbara Nicolosi: And oh by the way your first
project probably should be a feature.
Your first project should probably be a short
film.
Or an Internet web series that are five 2-minute
episodes.
Or something that kind of moves you into the
feature realm.
The feature storytelling is the hardest kind
of visual storytelling to do so why would
you start with that.
You know, you’ve got to walk before you
can run.
But you’ll have more confidence as you have
these little projects and then you work your
way up and say “Now I’m ready to write
my feature.”
It’s amazing how many people start writing
an epic scope…
Vicki Peterson: LAWRENCE OF ARABIA!
Barbara Nicolosi: A hundred million dollar
big-budget thing and it’s their first project.
And it’s like you’re just not ready to
do that.
Again, go back to the metaphor of the architect.
Don’t design a skyscraper as your first
thing and your first project needs to be small
in scope so you can get better.